don't fast feared about MRT you totally
stole our hearts in season 2 of scam nor
you're such a great character you're a
good friend and you're super smart and
you don't find it necessary to party
hard like your friends we weren't sure
William was really the best guy for you
but your love story turned out to be so
sweet the whole world became obsessed
with you too and now there are several
versions of you scam has several popular
international remakes and all the
original characters have counterparts
check out all seven versions of Nora and
William in this video keep watching to
find out which version you think is best
the original Nora and William we can't
talk about the international clones of
these characters without talking about
the originals we first met Nora and
William in season 1 of scam and season 2
Nora was the main character and most of
the storylines centered around her
romance with William my we are such
suckers for a good girl bad boy romance
that's why Nora and William are so
popular Noor is really smart and a great
friends William is a total party boy and
flirt but opposites attract
William is played by Thomas Hayes and
Nora is played by Josephine Frida
Peterson scam france scam has become
really popular in france the french
version which has the same name as the
original has a lot of similarities the
characters you have actual instagram
accounts Nora's counterpart is Manon de
Missy she is the central character in
season 2 she's pretty much exactly like
Nora and personality I did composed to
come over here to show me but she is a
brunette she does wear the same bright
red lipstick though MANET is played by
Marilyn Lima the French version of
William is named Charles Meuniere he has
lighter hair and a different build from
William but he's still a great boyfriend
to Mannin to discuss with you Charles is
played by Michael veal scam Austin scam
got so popular in the United States at
the show's creator headed overseas to
create a new version scam Austin takes
place in the capital city of Texas the
students attend Bolden high school the
show runs pretty much the same way as
the original start behaving like
but walking away like a cliche but there
is no official website all clips are
posted on social media grace Olsen is
the American version of Nora she has a
much more casual vibe she's played by
Kennedy Hermanson Williams counterpart
is Daniel Williamson played by Austin
Terry do I know you
he actually looks really similar to the
original William season 3 has an heir
yet but we are looking forward to it
scam NL just like the American version
the Dutch version has only two seasons
scammin L or scam Netherlands was the
sixth remake unlike the American version
it airs on television with full-length
episodes the second season is all about
live Ray's nur's fuel toys who is the
Dutch counterpart of Nora live is played
by Zoe love Smith she definitely has the
most different appearance of all the
nura's but she does a great job playing
the good girl in love with a bad boy
speaking of the bad boy the Dutch
version of William is Noah boom he is
played by monkey a galette he looks
pretty similar to the original William
don't you think direct the German
version of scam is super popular and has
already aired four seasons in less than
two years it even featured a one episode
special that took place between seasons
three and four just like the original
season two centers around the romance
between a good girl and a party guy but
smoosh kusuda in his version the good
girls named Mia winter she is played by
Melina shankha Mia looks pretty
different from the original Nora she
definitely brings her own flair to the
role Elena's a sinus kornkanok noona
hospit mention on sometime the German
version of William is Alexander
Hardenberg he's got the same great dark
hair that the other versions have he is
played by Christopher Paul Vera's scam
Italia the Italian version of scam
changes things up quite a bit first of
all it only featured three seasons it
also made the second season about
Martino who is the counterpart to Isaac
in the original and most other remakes
this is season 3 the Norah and Williams
storyline happened in the second season
of the original 20 but it was the third
season of scam italia these two
lovebirds are Eleonora Sava and Eduardo
in Conti Besson are you Bertie evanora
played by been dead egg agari
looks totally different from Norah but
Eduardo who is played by Giancarlo Khmer
has the same classic
look WTF ah the Belgian version of scam
definitely has the funniest title
Belgium was lucky because they got the
German version and the Belgian one-touch
asturias WT [ __ ] has already aired two
seasons season 3 will come out in the
fall of 2019 zoe locks is the
counterpart to Nora she's played by the
lovely Vere Leda shaker this is the only
counterpart to the platinum bonds like
the original Williams counterpart is
sandy Smith he is played by Nathan Annan
said ameno beautifully music Zita the
different countries definitely tried to
make sure Williams counterparts have a
very specific look he's got the hair and
a staredown perfectly scam espana our
last edition is scam espana the Spanish
version has changed the scam storyline
the most drastically the counterparts to
William and Nora don't have their own
seasons yet instead season two featured
Chris so de Pena who is based on two
original characters Chris Berg and Isaac
the Spanish Nora has an almost identical
name to the original though Nora grace
is played by Nicole Wallace she has a
very sweet innocent style by us Williams
character is Alejandro Beltran the dark
haired character is played by the actor
Fernando Lin des which version of scam
is your favorites let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to click Subscribe we'll see you
next time on two things
[Music]